theo i love your podcast with brendan
um i know that you're uh you're big on
fighting um
casey i know you were at the the triller
event uh
for jake paul so i wanted to see kind of
what you guys thoughts or predictions
were for uh this weekend uh
logan paul and floyd mann weather fight
um
just wanted to see uh if you guys had
any thoughts
uh if you you know were wanted to weigh
in
on it all right love you guys love you
thanks man
what do you think man you went to the
other one yeah i went to jake's fight
you see sugar shawn there
yeah i did yeah we hung out for a sec i
almost went
he's a cool guy yeah he's really cool
many guy
um yeah [ __ ]
[ __ ] logan paul mayweather
i mean it's a dream come true
um yeah i saw logan there actually
yeah i talked to him for a second he was
nice what was that event like
theo compared it to a jacksonville
nightclub all triller events
oh yeah i could see that yeah i've been
in some jacksonville nightclubs that
it was interesting a lot of underage
people there
so just a lot just just yeah just like
the lighting is all uh just just bizarre
kind of
but fun you know yeah it was like that
kind of bizarre
it was like it feels like that's what it
was it was like all
every every one of the biggest tick
tockers
were just hanging out with them it was
kind of like
i don't know it's kind of weird but it's
cool you dig like is that fun for you to
go do like an event like go to like a
big thing like that do you mind that
kind of stuff you do that kind of stuff
all the time like do you like to not
be like doing stuff like that um
yeah to go sometimes will you go to the
next one will you go to this logan one
no i'm gonna go i'm gonna be home i'm
going home tomorrow so
nice i might watch it on tv though you
watch it yeah
yeah i'll probably watch it i think that
i feel like unless i i i just question
is it some money play by the two of them
that's what i question
i think it is they stuck the whole thing
right right so are they going to make it
like a
but floyd's not going to take a loss so
he's undefeated
so he's not going to take a loss but
it's an exhibition accounts on his
record
i i read that they're not even going to
count they're not even going to announce
a winner
yeah really if it goes to decisions
they're just going to fight but you can
knock somebody out but they're not going
to announce that they want
huh i wonder what this all means then
it's [ __ ] stupid
yeah it's like but that's where we are i
think it's like it's becoming kind of
ancient rome
you know in this weird way i want to see
somebody fight an animal
yeah me too logan vs bear or something
[Laughter]
yeah or logan vs [ __ ] 20 [ __ ]
lizards you know like or just something
i think what's gonna happen is i i would
assume that
floyd is going to win um
i i just you're talking about one of
i'm not a floyd fan but you're talking
about one of the greatest fighters in
the
in the world yeah i mean he'll probably
win
i guess but like would be cool if logan
just knocked him out
oh i think it would be fascinating if he
did if he did
it's the whole world is going to change
like that's what i think we have to be
ready for if he [ __ ] knocks him out
oh yeah there's maybe some new genders
afoot for sure
yeah dude there's gonna be some race
ride i mean there's gonna be all kind of
stuff that's gonna happen
yeah i could see like a race riot or
something yeah
people yelling he's guilty and just
burning down st louis
[Laughter]
but i think what do you see it happening
how do you even see the fight going
do you think uh
i feel like i wish they just knew each
other better
i just wish that there was more of a
story between them like they'd gone to
prison together or something or they had
like a history or they had
right one of them's parents had dated or
something or one of their moms that died
in a car fire
or floyd's dad yeah or just someone
there was some like yeah saved logan or
something from
yeah like i wish somebody just had like
a um yeah and it saved logan
from a whale yeah yeah or something
wacky i don't know
yeah they yeah i just wish there would
be there's just more story to it
floyd versus diarrhea would be cool oh
yeah i could see that
i think he could beat diarrhea
but yeah i don't know man i think like
mayweather will probably win but maybe
logan probably thrown trying to just
knock him out i guess like he'll
probably try to get close to him and
just see if he can hit him with
something yeah and floyd how old is
floyd now
it's like 68 no
in feral years oh yeah i could see him
44. and logan's what 26
six yeah so look uh you're you're gonna
learn a lot
i think people are gonna learn a lot
i think what do you think happens nick i
think floyd knocks him out i mean
if he knocks him out late floyd will
knock him out late like
round seven eight he'll just toy with
him similar the counter fight he'll get
tired and that'll knock him out
if k if logan can't be ksi like
definitively does floyd is he known for
knocking people out
or is he like he did conor it was like
the same thing he just kind of toyed
with him and then conor got tired and he
knocked him out in the 10th or 11th uh
i forgot about that for years he hasn't
been knocking people out though like
decision canelo decision i think yeah
he's just like a good boxer right like
yeah
he's just so fast dodging it yeah i
think it'd be interesting i think
i just wonder if there's another deal
going on behind the scene between them
where it's like
hey let it go at least five rounds you
know i don't know but
it'll be exciting it'll be interesting
to see [ __ ] that's going to be weird
when that bell rings out when you're
logan you're walking across the ring
i know i'm excited i'm going to watch it
back home probably big screen outdoors
oh really yeah you guys do it like that
huh yeah
drag out the ethernet cord
watching the ganja patch damn that's
beautiful man
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another
and you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices
some guy just brings you one option not
this guy
two options watch one this one or this
one